hey this is presto Walker what is 6 plus
66 plus 666 plus so on where each new
number has one more digit and one more 6
and you continue the pattern all the way
until a number which has only sixes for
666 digits can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
so let me first explain the answer to
this problem one way you could write the
answer is in the following form it'll be
six ninths times the following quantity
we first have a fraction where the
numerator is 10 to the power of 667
minus 10 and the denominator is 9 we
then subtract 666 from that fraction but
what is this as a number we could write
it out in decimal form in the following
fashion
it's a 666 digit number which has the
string 740 repeated over and over again
until the very last three digits which
are 296 so the string 740 is repeated
and consists of 663 of the digits of the
666 digit number so how do we derive
these answers in order to explain the
proof I want to go over a concept that
is central to the proofs this will be
the sum of a geometric series let's
consider a geometric series which has K
terms and a common ratio R so we start
out with 1 and then we're going to
multiply that to get the next term which
is R we then multiply R by the common
ratio R again to get R squared and we
continue and we keep adding terms all
the way until we get to the K term which
is R to the power of K minus 1 to find
the sum we do a neat little trick we
multiply the sum
the common ratio are look at what this
will do to each term the first term one
becomes R the second term R becomes R
squared and pattern continues we've
essentially shifted over the summation
and we get one more new term R to the
power of K we now subtract the second
equation from the first this will cancel
out many terms in particular we cancel
out the ars we can select the R squares
we cancel out all of these middle terms
and we cancel out R to the power of K
minus 1 when we subtract the two
equations the only terms that survive
are 1 and minus R to the power of K we
now factor S sub K on the left hand side
and then we divide both sides by 1 minus
R and that's the formula that we want
the sum of a geometric series will be
equal to a fraction where the numerator
is 1 minus R to the power of K and the
denominator is 1 minus R sometimes it'll
be convenient to multiply the numerator
and denominator by negative 1 and that's
the formula used in this video which is
R to the power of K minus 1 all over R
minus 1 one more note let's suppose we
have a geometric series that starts out
with some other term a we then
essentially multiplied each term by a so
that will also multiply our sum by a so
these would be our formulas if our
geometric series started out with the
term a for completeness I'll mention
that if we were dealing with an infinite
series if our common ratio has an
absolute value of less than 1 then we
could find the sum of the infinite
series by taking the limit as K goes to
infinity and this will become the
well-known formula of the sum of the
geometric series which is a divided by 1
minus R so now let's get to the problem
well generalize by saying the last
number we're adding has n digits the
first step is
factor out a 6 from each term so we now
have six multiplied by the following sum
1 plus 11 plus 111 plus so on all the
way until the last term has only ones
for n digits we now write out each term
in expanded form so one stays is 1 but
11 will become 1 plus 10 similarly the
next term which would be 111 will be 1
plus 10 plus 100 and we continue writing
this all the way until the very last
term which is only 1 for n digits so
what would be the expanded form of this
we basically be adding up the powers of
10 1 plus 10 plus 100 plus so on all the
way up to 10 to the power of n minus 1
now we notice a pattern in the summation
each of the parenthetical terms will be
a geometric series with a common ratio
10 and a different parameter with a
different number of terms so we can now
use the formula for the sum of geometric
series for each of these groups so 1 can
be re-written as 10 minus 1 divided by 9
1 plus 10 can be re-written as 10
squared minus 1 over 9 and we can keep
writing each of these grouped terms in
that way until the very last term which
we will get as 10 to the power of n
minus 1 all over 9 now what we can do
this term is that we can factor out a
1/9 from each of the terms in the
summation so we have six ninths times
the following summation we have some
powers of 10 being added together and we
have negative 1 in each of these groups
so now let's rearrange the terms in this
summation
well group all the powers of 10 on the
left and all the negative ones on the
right now each of the groups had a
negative 1 so
we'll be in terms of negative one this
will simplify to be negative n now we
have something magical we'll factor out
a 10 and it'll make it a little more
explicit that we have another geometric
series so again we can use the formula
for the sum of a geometric series so we
end up with the following formula and
this will be very close to the answer I
presented earlier once we distribute the
10 so we have 10 to the power of n plus
1 minus 10 all over 9 then we subtract
10 and we multiply the entire thing by
six nines
to get to our specific case where we had
666 equal to n we substitute that in and
we get the answer that I presented
earlier so now how can we write this out
as a decimal number well what we can do
is we can expand the exponent 10 to the
power of 667 will be a number that's 1
followed by a bunch of zeros this number
will have 668 digits we now subtract 10
so when we have a number that's 1
followed by a bunch of zeros and we
subtract out 10 we're gonna end up with
the number that's all these nines and
the very last two digits are 90 this
number in particular will have one fewer
digits so it'll be 667 digits long we
now need to divide by 9 so a number that
has only nines and then a 90 at the end
when we divide that by 9 it'll have only
ones and then a zero at the end it'll
still be the same number of digits we'll
now distribute the term six over nine to
each of these so then we can simplify by
multiplying 6 ninths times these terms
so the first thing that'll be easier as
16 times 666 and that'll be 444 now how
do we figure out the older
multiplication well you can try and do a
little bit of long division and you'll
quickly notice a pattern
you'll basically end up with 740 being
repeated over and over again so 663 of
these digits will be 740 the last three
will also be 740 but those last three
will be affected by subtracting out by
444 so we'll now subtract out which will
affect the last three digits and those
have become 296 so that's how we get to
this answer of a 666 digit number where
the first 663 are 740 and the last three
are 296 and that's going to be the
answer to this problem which we also
write in this other alternate way did
you figure out this problem thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch around my blog my dear decisions
that you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch her on social
media at pressure Locker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description